[Music]
maybe the best part of this whole trip
to Korea was that I made so many friends
and met so many fans check this out this
is amazing someone made this it's a box
a completely handmade paper box with my
face on it and then you take this out
and it's a complete summary of my career
late night show and the dates that it
started and ended to tonight's show
Conan in Korea how long I was there
gorgeous workmanship you've got this
right here someone I think must have
purchased this I don't know what this
has to do with me I guess the word is
out that I'm incontinent
in South Korea and I have to wear a
diaper that's true and that I also were
a cape and then there's a letter here my
name is Eugene Jiu I'm 18 years old and
I'm your big fan thank you for visiting
here South Korea I didn't expect that
you're visiting Korea because of the
snack lol sometimes I always think that
your long legs are too sexy like a
grasshopper my present is cute hand
cream when I watch the clip sometimes
your hands look little dry I hope you
have a great time in Korea and thank you
for visiting PS how about visiting North
Korea it will be fun yes sure it would
be a lot of fun just never get out and
you're right my hands if you can get in
there I do have the hands of a mummy
here's a nice letter first of all that's
a great drawing of me neck a little
thicker than I would like I look like
I'm choking on a giant ham dear Conan
it's always hard to think the first
sentence of letter yes I want to start
this letter by asking how are you it's
because the weather in Korea suddenly
got freezing and I'm worried about your
health as I got sick yesterday because
of the weather surprisingly I became
okay as I fell asleep in pain fell
asleep in pain you know what you are
magic I hope you have amazing time in
Korea PS the painting on the back is you
don't be suspicious I let my sister to
draw your portrait in the exchange of my
lipstick and doing her housework thank
you from your fan
Shari Lee look at this one this is to
Conan God of late-night show I like that
and that is my legal title then there's
something in here looks like it's a cat
look at this letter right here
hello Conan I'm go on Lee one of your
fans in Korea not North Korea when I
feel hard for my daily lives I watch
your show and receive a lot of positive
energy from your sarcastic and smart
jokes and laughs which makes me study
English hard and go to the USA I really
keep in mind your comment in Conan
late-night show final episode if you
work really hard and you are kind
amazing things will happen I believe
that's true thanks for being alive
you're welcome that it's not my yes I am
very happy to be alive thanks for being
alive and continuing the show I wish you
would enjoy the visit in South Korea
have a good memory with all my heart and
respect and that says go in Lee that's a
really really nice letter look at this
is an amazing one reasons why I like
Conan so much bye chai Jung Lee there
are a lot of reasons my antics that's me
I think having a seizure of some kind I
guess that's me being clever talking to
a young fan I like the way I'm dressed
there I look cool I like your antics you
always said you make money off your
mental illness but crazy people is just
love of my life they always make me
laugh and I can't take my eyes off of
them she's just hypnotized by crazy
people I love this when I was lonely I
watched your show when you made me laugh
dot dot most of the time well sorry
that's the truest thing I've heard in a
while this is great I love this one
this fan took a poster of obviously Star
Wars and made it Team Coco visits Korea
and you see all the important characters
in my life like andy sona jordan
shlonsky who actually looks like he's in
a Star Wars movie who is that way back
there that Megan Sinclair photographer
at the show I didn't really know people
knew about Megan but apparently they do
and then I love this part I did my best
well I think your best is terrific
and of course this the most passionate
letter of all that I received
dear Conan hi I am Seung Joo nothing
shows passion for Conan like that simple
line identifying who you are I
absolutely
adore these letters they're really sweet
and creative and thank you very very
much I wish I could read them all here
on camera but that would take 15 years
thank you
[Music]
you